welcome to cbs this morning we're going
to begin with this
we are still talking about the story and
rightfully so because we're learning
more and more about how close we came
to even more violence when a mob whipped
up by president trump
stormed the u.s capitol as rioters
attacked police officers with any object
they could find
some lawmakers were evacuated with only
seconds to spare
they barely escaped a mob that seemed
hell-bent on causing mam
the shocking new details are spurring on
calls for the president to resign
or be impeached or be forced from office
by his own cabinet
we have a team of reporters covering all
angles of this
we start with nancy cordes on capitol
hill nancy how is this being dealt with
in the house
things are moving very quickly anthony
last night the house speaker nancy
pelosi announced that she would be
bringing the entire house back
tomorrow to vote on a resolution
demanding that the vice president
invoke the 25th amendment and remove the
president from
office with one week left in his term
if that doesn't work she says they're
moving the next day to plan b
impeachment and does it actually make
sense
well i let the 25th amendment because it
gets rid of him
he's out of office in her first
interview since wednesday's attack on
the capitol
house speaker nancy pelosi told 60
minutes there are multiple avenues to
hold
president trump accountable this
president is guilty
of inciting insurrection insurrection
he has to pay a price for that nearly
every house democrat has now signed on
to the three-page impeachment resolution
accusing the president of inciting an
insurrection
we're going to the capitol that means if
it comes up for a vote this week
it is very likely to pass donald trump
may be
in the twitter penalty box but he still
has access to the nuclear codes
that's a frightening prospect house
majority whip jim clyburn suggested that
if the article of impeachment passes
speaker pelosi could hold off on sending
it to the senate
let's give president elect biden
the hundred days he needs to get his
agenda off
and running and maybe we'll send
the articles sometimes after that it's
unclear if a second impeachment would be
more successful in the senate this time
but two republicans are calling on the
president to step
down alaska's lisa murkowski and
pennsylvania's pat
toomey i think the best way for our
country chuck is for the president to
resign
and go away as soon as possible many
republicans
eager to avoid a tough vote insist
impeaching president trump will just
fan the flames this is a heated
political moment we've got to be able to
bring volume down
some of the strongest opposition comes
from republicans who
led the charge to baselessly contest the
election results
i do not see how that unifies the
country those republicans are now
facing internal condemnation from some
of their own
gop colleagues they did it either to
save their own political skins
or to make a quick fundraising buck
and those lawmakers he talked about now
face calls from hometown newspapers to
resign
as corporations from marriott to
citibank
hit pause on political giving to those
who voted against
certification of the election and we
expect that number of corporations
to grow tony in time voters will have
their say as well nancy thank you very
much